moving on and Israeli forces have killed
a Palestinian during fighting in the
city of Jericho in the occupied West
Bank
Israel says a female Soldier was wounded
during the violence meanwhile the U.N
wants the Israeli authorities to
investigate another incident that took
place in Hebron last month five
Palestinian women were reportedly
subjected to abuse by female soldiers
who forced them to take off their
clothes during a search
on the north of the occupied West Bank
Israeli forces have carried out a raid
on the city of Janine there were reports
of gunfire as dozens of armored vehicles
moved through the city the Palestinian
Alexa Marta's brigades says one of its
leaders has been arrested well let's
speak to Paul Brennan he's in Ramallah
in the occupied West Bank Paul I believe
this was a brief but rather heavily
armed raid in Janine
certainly yes and the second one in a
week which kind of is Raising tension
certainly here in the occupied West Bank
the rate itself began just after nine
and was all over by around 10 but
nevertheless the brevity of it uh does
not undermine the importance of it the
Israeli forces arrested a senior leader
uh within the Al-Aqsa Brigade that's the
armed wing of fatah his name is Mohammed
magnagia he's well known to the
authorities he's served multiple prison
terms for various shootings and weapons
offenses but at the same time he's also
played a role in the Palestinian
authorities security and intelligence
apparatus so you know it shows you the
Blurred Lines sometimes that there are
in these part of the worlds and and
coming so soon after Monday's raid in
the same area of Janine that raid
targeting a Hamas operatives within the
Janine Camp
um there is the growing tension that two
two months after the big raids of July
the big rate of July the tension is
ramping up again I put one note of
caution on that the the impression that
we have certainly here in Ramallah is
these were more opportunist raids
perhaps acting on specific intelligence
to arrest specific people
um but nonetheless the fact that the
Israeli army goes in in this manner
raises the tension Paul as you alluded
to their tensions feel like they're
mounting across the occupied West Bank
with several incidents should we make
anything of that
well certainly the number of people
killed by Israeli forces in the occupied
territories is now fast approaching 200
I think the latest count was 197 as of
this morning
and the memories of that July 3rd raid
into the Janine Camp are both recent and
very raw indeed 13 Palestinians lost
their lives nine of them were Fighters
more than 100 people were wounded in
that particular Israeli Army operation
and the as you say the the tension that
that puts into the already strained
relations uh but also into the way that
the Palestinian Authority tries to uh
liaise and and govern and police at the
Janine area it certainly increases the
tension doesn't make it easy for anybody
in this in this particular part of the
world Paul Brennan there with the latest
force from Ramallah in the occupied West
Bank thank you very much Paul